Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 276, wo wir uns jetzt mit einem Thema beschäftigen wollen, das schon nicht mehr aktuell ist, weil es den aktuellen Nachrichtenzyklus so ein bisschen verlassen hat und es gibt andere wichtige Dinge. Aber was andererseits brandaktuell ist, weil es noch lange nicht vorbei ist, wovon ich rede, ist die sogenannte Chatkontrolle. Und selbst wenn ihr davon noch nichts gehört habt, habt ihr wahrscheinlich das Wort schon mal gehört, weil es tatsächlich für ein paar Tage, Wochen sehr gut durch die Medien flog und jetzt immer noch so ein bisschen immanent da ist, aber schon ein bisschen weniger. Und wir wollen das heute, wie es Chaosradioart ist, eben einmal auseinandernehmen, aufrollen, wieder zumachen und dann gucken, was wir dagegen unternehmen können. Weil ja, es ist eines dieser Themen, wo Dinge anstehen. Und dazu begrüße ich recht herzlich Khaleesi und Viktor, zwei Menschen, die sich mit diesem Thema beschäftigt haben, vor allen Dingen mit dem Auseinandernehmen und die heute hier zu Gast sind. Der Reihe nach, wer seid ihr, was macht ihr und was befähigt euch, über das Thema Chatkontrolle zu sprechen, Khaleesi?
Ein Fingerabdruck könnte man sagen.
Also was ich gerne über Hashes sage, ist, alle digitalen Daten sind ja Zahlen letztlich. Und man kann auf digitale Daten Mathe raufwerfen, da kommt ein eindeutiger Wert drauf. Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn man was reinwirft, und da kommt hinten derselbe Wert raus, kann man relativ sicher sein, dass man vorne wieder dasselbe reingeworfen hat.
Genau, das ist eine viel bessere Erklärung als meine. Was heißt das also? Wir haben also diese Hash-Datenbank. Und wir müssten dann auf unserem Gerät, also wenn ich jetzt an Viktor zum Beispiel ein Bild schicken möchte, würde dieses Bild auf meinem Gerät gehashed werden. Und es würde geschaut werden, ob in dieser Bilddatenbank dieser Hash schon liegt. Und wenn ja, würde das als verdächtiges Material markiert werden und dann entsprechend ausgeleitet werden. Also an Ermittlungsbehörden weitergeleitet.
Also würde automatisch dahin geschickt werden?
Genau.
Aber das hört sich doch erstmal gar nicht so schlecht an eigentlich.
Ja, aber es gibt mehrere Dinge, die man bedenken muss. Erstmal würde das heißen, dass wirklich alles erstmal abgeglichen werden muss. Und wer die Macht über diese Datenbank hat, hat auch die Macht darüber, was weitergeleitet wird. Also weitergeleitet nicht an meinen Kommunikationspartner, sondern weitergeleitet an die entsprechende Behörde, die diese ganze Geschichte überwacht.
Okay, vielleicht könnte man noch einsteigen und sagen, das Wichtigste ist ja eigentlich, das Ding ist völlig unwirksam, weil das völlig ein Problem vorbei ist. Das zweite Ding ist, das ist gefährlich, weil es erstens nicht praktikabel ist, die wenigen Kindesmissbrauchs- Abbildungen überhaupt zu finden. Weil jetzt kann man sich überlegen, wie tut man das? Entweder man sagt, wir suchen bekanntes Material, da muss man irgendwo eine Liste haben von allen bekannten Kindesmissbrauchs- Abbildungen. Oder man sagt, wir bauen da eine zauberhafte KI, die dazu in der Lage ist, aber auch die wird Fehler machen.
Aber wir wollten ja jetzt erstmal grundsätzlich nur bei Kleinzeitscanning bleiben, wenn ich Marcus richtig verstanden hat. Und noch keinen Abstecher über alles machen. Deswegen sag ich, wir gehen jetzt von bekanntem Material aus grundsätzlich, was ist Kleinzeitscanning und was ist das Problem.
Genau, das hab ich jetzt nicht verstanden. Weil, wenn man von diesen Hashwerten ausgeht, die sind ja relativ genau. Das heißt, ich würde sagen, also gut, das Gerät rechnet diesen Wert auf. Das passiert auch nur bei mir auf dem Gerät. Und erst, wenn ich da wirklich exakt dasselbe Bild habe, wie in der Datemang hinterlegt ist, dann wird das ausgehalten. Jetzt gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten von Missbrauch, die ich mir da vorstellen kann. Die will ich jetzt erst mal abfragen. Das eine ist, es hat ja in der Vergangenheit auch so Einzelfälle gegeben. Also irgendwie Polizisten nutzen Datenbanken, um Person X, Y zu stalken. Ist das was, was man auch hier sozusagen nimmt? Also irgendjemand macht einen Hashtag in die Daten, Hashtag in die Datenbank und sagt, schick mir mal dieses sexy Bild von diesem Blumentopf und leite das aus. Oder ist das eher hier kein Problem, das gesehen wird?
Also wenn wir uns das Gesetz anschauen, ist es halt so, dass diese Behörde grundsätzlich an Europol angegliedert wird. Und mehr weiß man noch nicht genau. Also die wird jetzt auch schon aufgebaut im Hintergrund, obwohl diese Verordnung noch gar nicht durch ist. Ich persönlich würde grundsätzlich das Missbrauchspotenzial höher einschätzen, wenn es um politische Dinge geht. Das beste Beispiel ist ein Demo-Aufruf. Wenn ich rausfinden will, wer alles auf eine Demo gehen wird, oder wenn ich Bilder einfach aus dem europäischen Raum verschwinden lassen will, kann das auch entsprechend gesperrt werden. Das ist das höchste Missbrauchspotenzial. Ich kann dafür sorgen, dass bestimmte Bilder gar nicht mehr im europäischen Rechtsraum auftauchen würden und dadurch ganze Dinge unterbinden.
Das ist ein mögliches Missbrauchsszenario. Das steht so im Gesetzesentwurf nicht drin. Was ich noch sagen würde, eigentlich geht es um vertrauenswürdige Kommunikation. Wenn ich Khaleesi eine Nachricht schreibe, möchte ich sicher sein, dass ich vertrauen kann, dass sie nur bei ihr landet. Das Problem mit Kleinstzeitsscanning ist, dass ich meinem Gerät nicht mehr vertrauen kann. Da ist wie eine kleine Person auf meinem Gerät, was sich jede von meinen Chatnachrichten anguckt und jedes Bild und jeweils kurz sich an den Bart fasst und mir legt, ist das eigentlich gut oder nicht? Und wenn ich Pech habe, aus richtigen oder falschen Gründen, wird mein Gerät sich gegen mich entscheiden und eloyal werden. Und statt die Nachricht, die ich eigentlich Khaleesi schicken wollte, tatsächlich an Khaleesi zu schicken, einfach jemand anderem schicken. Das heißt, mein Gerät hat wie eine PET-Funktion eingebaut, von der ich nicht sicher sein kann, dass sie korrekt funktioniert und dass sie auf jeden Fall technisch in der Lage ist, Dinge, die wirklich nur für Khaleesi gedacht waren, an irgendjemand anderes zu schicken. Und das ist ein massives Problem, weil ich nicht bei jeder Nachricht weiß, ich kann mir nicht mehr sicher sein. Das ist relativ wahrscheinlich. Aber ich weiß nicht genau, wie gut diese kleine Person, die da sitzt und sich am Bad krault, wie gut die diese Sachen entscheiden kann. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie gut die in der Lage ist, wie wohlgesonnen die mir ist, ob ich mich gut verstehe oder nicht. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Und die kann auch einfach Fehler machen. Wir können uns nicht mehr darauf verlassen, dass das tatsächlich passiert. Das ist das Problem.
D.h. ihr habt ein ganz grundsätzliches Misstrauen gegenüber EU-Behörden.
Hör ich das richtig raus? Ich glaube, ja. Ein grundsätzliches Misstrauen gegenüber EU-Behörden ist durchaus angemessen. Wenn man als Beispiel nimmt, dass Europol ungern illegal erhobene Daten löschen möchte, kann man da durchaus von einem Misstrauen ausgehen. Aber ich glaube, was uns an dieser Stelle viel wichtiger ist, der Punkt ist, dass wir vertrauenswürdige Kommunikation sicherstellen. Das ist mein Gerät. Ich vergleiche das immer mit einem Tagebuch. Ein Smartphone ist eigentlich das persönlichste, was wir haben. Wir tippen da alle unsere eigenen Gedanken drin. Wir tippen da alle Gedanken, die wir mit der Familie oder Freundinnen und PartnerInnen teilen möchten rein. Und genauso wie beim Tagebuch wollen wir ja auch wirklich, wirklich, wirklich die Macht darüber haben, wer da reingucken darf und wer nicht. Und das ist glaube ich der Punkt, der hier so massiv wichtig ist, dass mein Gerät, also dass ich der Herr oder die Herrin meines Gerätes bin und durch Kleinzeitscanning würde dieser Part mir genommen werden. Und das ist für mich das größte und das schlimmste Störgefühl, was man eigentlich haben kann. Also Sicherheitsforscherinnen haben das als diese ganze Apple-Debatte zu Kleinzeitscanning aufgekommen, als The Bugs in our Pockets bezeichnet. Und das ist halt sehr treffend. Also das führt auch zu anderen Sicherheitsimplikationen, aber primär halt dazu, dass ich meinem Gerät nicht mehr vertrauen kann.
Und wir können vielleicht auch sagen, wir haben ja nicht mal, also ich persönlich halte das nicht mal eine, eine Fehler aus bösem Willen für das wahrscheinlich, sondern einfach aus Inkompetenz, slash fehlender Leistung von diesen Erkennungssystemen. Weil wenn wir uns überlegen, wir haben, ich glaube, eine halbe Milliarde Chatnachrichten pro Tag in der EU, da ist jedes System, was sich auch nur bei jeder tausendsten Nachricht irrt, da entstehen immer noch gigantische Mengen an Chatnachrichten, die völlig unberechtigterweise an die Polizei weitergeleitet wurden. Und bei jeder Chatnachricht von mir weiß ich da nicht genau, okay ja fuck, wenn ich im Jahr 10.000 Nachrichten verschicke und dieses Ding jede tausendste Sache fälschlicherweise erkennt, dann dann Jahrzehntnachrichten pro Jahr bei der Polizei von mir. Welche denn jetzt? Ist es jetzt die nächste? Keine Ahnung. Und dieses Urvertrauen in meinen verschlüsselten Kanal, das ist dann halt weg.
Ich frage mich gerade, ist euch in der Diskussion, wenn ihr das sozusagen vortragt, auch schon das Argument begegnet, weil also ich habe das in anderen Situationen manchmal gehört, deswegen frage ich euch das jetzt, dass Leute dann sagen, ja na gut, das ist schon was anderes, aber die Leute geben ja in sozialen Netzwerken eh so viel von sich preis, da macht das ja auch keinen Unterschied mehr.
Also diese Frage ist uns tatsächlich noch nicht so begegnet, deswegen finde ich das sehr interessant. Mein Argument wäre da einfach, man könnte es auch ein bisschen naiv nennen, aber Menschen sind sich ja in sozialen Netzwerken darüber bewusst, dass das öffentlich einsehbar ist. Wenn ich jetzt aber meinen Partner, meiner Partnerin zum Beispiel Nacktbild schicken möchte, dann habe ich ja überhaupt gar kein Interesse daran, dass es jemals von irgendjemand anderem außer meinem Partner oder meiner Partnerin gesehen werden wird. So. Und ich glaube, das ist der entscheidende Unterschied. Und ich glaube, das ist auch etwas, was uns allen klar ist, dass es einfach Dinge gibt, die wir auch so nie auf öffentlichen Social Media Kanälen teilen wollen.
Gibt es denn eigentlich bei diesem Ding, das ist ja bei anderen Überwachungsgesetzgebungen manchmal passiert, dass Leute gesagt haben, also das wollen wir vor allen Dingen machen, um Missbrauchsabbildungen zu verhindern. Und dann kommt irgendwie drei Tage, drei Monate, sechs Jahre später, jemand sagt, ja, aber wir können es auch für Steuerverhandlungen benutzen oder bei Drogendelikten oder bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen. Ist das hier auch schon sozusagen, gibt es da auch schon Leute, die diese Idee haben?
Ja, und das ist tatsächlich total interessant. Also wir sind jetzt noch nicht in das Rechtliche so eingestiegen. Aber das ist nicht nur die Ablösung für die bisherige bestehende Verordnung, sondern es ist auch eine Spezifizierung für den Digital Services Act. Also der Digital Services Act, der ist, ich glaube aus der Datenschutzbubble gesehen, relativ glimpflich verlaufen und relativ gut für uns verlaufen. Aber alles, was sie sozusagen im Digital Services Act nicht durchbekommen haben, finden wir jetzt in dieser Verordnung wieder. Und diese Verordnung ist halt sehr generell und schwammig formuliert. Und jetzt, ich sag mal, Kindesmissbrauchs-Darstellung durch Terror zum Beispiel auszutauschen, ist nicht so wahnsinnig weit hergeholt. Also man muss sich immer der Sache bewusst sein, dass wenn man durch eine solche Verordnung ein derartiges Überwachungswerkzeug schafft, schafft es auch immer die Möglichkeit, es auf andere Bereiche auszuweiten. Weil es ist da und ob ich jetzt nach Kindesmissbrauchs-Darstellung im Form von Bild-Hashes suche oder nach Terror-Darstellung, sag ich mal so in Anführungsstrichen, der Unterschied ist technologiebezogen gar nicht so riesig.
Also das heißt, es gibt noch konkret keine Ansätze, von denen ihr gehört habt, aber ihr geht davon aus, dass könnte dann zu leicht passieren.
Ja, man muss auch immer sagen, wenn wir solche Werkzeuge bauen, dann baut Meta das Jahr. Und Meta gibt es nicht nur in Europa. Das heißt, es ist ja nicht nur so, dass dieses Werkzeug durch neue Gesetzgebungen auf EU-Ebene missbraucht werden kann, sondern dass, wenn wir in repressiven Staaten landen mit diesen entsprechenden Firmen, die sagen, hm, also für die EU, da habt ihr doch diese coole Clientside Scanning Technologie gebaut. Wir haben hier so ein paar politische Gruppen, die uns ein bisschen nerven. Wir würden das jetzt gerne nutzen, um deren Kommunikation mal ein bisschen zu überwachen und zu stören. So, der Sache sollte man sich halt auch bewusst sein, die man da im Hinterkopf behalten sollte.
Ist das eigentlich sozusagen im Endeffekt dann so ein bisschen eine Diskussion, dass die Befürworter sagen, ja gut, man kann das richtig bauen und dann funktioniert das auch und die KritikerInnen, die sagen so, ne, alleine die Idee macht das System quasi kaputt.
Also, ich hab noch überhaupt keine Vorstellung gesehen von irgendjemand, wie man das technisch korrekt bauen könnte. Tatsächlich, also niemand in diesem Gesetz steht das nicht drin und niemand konnte überzeugend, für mich persönlich überzeugend darstellen, wie man das alles technisch umsetzen könnte, ohne dass es eine völlige Katastrophe wird. Du siehst nachdenklich aus.
Naja, also ich glaube der wichtige Punkt ist, also was heißt technisch korrekt bauen? Also, diese Medaille hat für mich zwei Seiten. Nämlich einmal die Seite, können wir es privatsphärefreundlich bauen, so wie wir DatenschützerInnen uns das vorstellen. Und die andere Seite der Medaille ist aber, können wir es so bauen, dass es nicht für andere Zwecke missbraucht werden kann. Das sind für mich zwei Seiten der Medaille. Die Befürworterinnen werden jetzt sagen, naja, wir haben das in der Verordnung ja so pro Privatsphäre geregelt, dass das ja gar nicht zu missbrauchen ist. Aber was sie nicht betrachtet haben, ist halt das, was ich eben gerade gesagt hab. Wenn man ein solches Werkzeug schafft, kann das immer für andere Dinge verwendet werden.
Und es ist einfach eine super, wie du gesagt hast, eine super Argumentationshilfe für irgendwelche repressiven Staaten. Auch auf dem politischen Parkett zu sagen, hey, ihr macht das doch auch, ich will das jetzt auch haben. Und was ich noch ergänzen wollte, ist, wenn man sich die netzpolitische Geschichte der letzten sechs, sieben Jahre der EU anguckt, ich hab das mal ein bisschen zusammengefasst für heute, es ist die ganze Zeit, seit 2015, fordert da irgendjemand und hat irgendeine Sicherheitsbehörde die tolle Idee, dass die Verschlüsselung schon auch ein Problem ist und dass es doch eigentlich direkten Zugriff für Sicherheitsbehörden auf eigentlich verschlüsselte Inhalte geben müsste, was wiederum nur eine der fünf von mir vorhin vorgestellten Lösungsansätze braucht. Staatstrojaner, Client-Site-Scanning, diese Sachen. Und die ganze Zeit, da gibt es einen tollen Netzpolitikartikel dazu, den machen wir vielleicht auch in die Show notes, die ganze Zeit, seitdem sagt irgendwie der britische Premierminister, wir wollen das verbieten, wenn wir nicht reingucken können, sagt die EU, ach ja, wir hätten hier gerne eigentlich, wir wollen auch Zugang zu Staats- und Sicherheitsbehörden. Sagen die Five Eyes, also USA, Kanada, Australien, England, Australien sagen hier, das ist ja ein totales Problem, dass wir da nicht mehr reingucken können. Gibt es dieses Going Dark-Narrativ von, wir als Geheimdienst können gar nicht mehr arbeiten, wenn ihr jetzt hier alles verschlüsselt habt. Und es gab sogar 2020, also nicht lange her, unter deutschem EU-Ratsvorsitz gab es diese Entschließung. Da hat Khaleesi gerade schon erzählt, von Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung, nennen sie das. Und auch da formulieren sie, na ja, eigentlich muss es doch trotz Verschlüsselung irgendeine Möglichkeit geben, bitte, dass wir auf die Inhalte zugreifen können, selbst wenn die Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt waren. Und wenn man das jetzt so zieht, also wenn man diese ganzen Punkte verbindet und guckt...
Das ist eigentlich die Perfektion. Sie haben eine neue juristische Perfektion erreicht in diesem Gesetzesvorschlag.
Genau, und das ist jetzt vielleicht eine Unterstellung, weil das hat natürlich niemand damit begründet. Aber einfach jetzt, wenn man sich nur diese Datenpunkte anguckt, dass da seit fünf, sechs Jahren Rumor hat, dass in diesem Kessel und jedes Jahr kommt irgendjemand auf die Idee zu fordern, ey, eigentlich müssen wir da was machen. Dieses Gesetz ist jetzt nicht mal per se dazu geeignet, richtig an die Inhalte in großer Menge ranzukommen. Aber es ist trotzdem ein brachialer Angriff auf dieses Konzept von wirklich vertrauenswürdiger Kommunikation, wo ich wirklich sehr vertrauen kann, dass die Inhalte nur bei der Person ankommen, an die ich sie geschickt hab, und damit für sich absolut in dieser Reihe zu sehen.
Ja, aber da muss man doch mal fragen, wenn die Experten seit Jahren daran arbeiten, warum zur Hölle ist euch denn jetzt diese vertrauliche Kommunikation so wichtig?
Ich glaube, wir sollten da zu zwei Seiten zurückgehen. Erstmal würde ich gerne zu diesem Thema repressive Staaten zurückgehen. Also, in Deutschland könnte man so sagen, ja, wenn ich hier Viktor einen Demo-Aufruf gegen die Chatkontrolle schicke, auch wenn die Bundesregierung das doof findet, ist das nicht so das Problem, weil eine freie Meinungsäußerung ist für uns gesichert. Aber wenn ich in ein anderes Land gehe, dann kann das schon sein, dass das zur politischen Verfolgung führen kann. Das heißt, erst mal, damit ich demonstrieren kann oder Informationen zu irgendwelchen Sachen, gegen die man politisch sein kann, austauschen kann, ist das total wichtig. Dann gibt es natürlich Berufsgruppen, die grundsätzlich Interesse an vertrauenswürdiger Kommunikation haben. Also Anwältinnen, Ärztinnen, aber auch Journalistinnen. Und wir haben vorhin schon mal den Namen Edward Snowden gehört. Whistleblowerin, die halt wirklich gefährdet sein können, wenn irgendwie rauskommt, dass sie Dinge weitergegeben haben oder nach außen kommuniziert haben.
Also es ist quasi ein gesellschaftlich wichtiges Ding, dass wir einen Weg haben, wirklich unter uns zu bleiben.
Genau, also das ist, genau, also es, ich sag mal, es gibt ja so dieses, diesen Begriff von dem Chilling Effect, das ist im Rahmen dieser Reclaim Your Faces Kampagne auch sehr schön erklärt. Das Video können wir gerne auch nochmal verlinken. Das heißt, wenn ich weiß, dass ich prinzipiell beobachtet werde, verhalte ich mich automatisch konformer zu zum Beispiel dem Regime, in dem ich mich bewege. So, das hat halt sehr krasse Auswirkungen auf meine Meinungsäußerung und auch die Art, wie ich mich zum Beispiel politisch organisieren würde, wenn ich mit etwas, was in meinem Land passiert ist, politisch nicht so einverstanden bin.
Und es ist realistisch gesehen auch deine einzige Art, deine einzige Chance, dich zu Protest zu verabreden in einem repressiven Überwachungsstaat.
Mir ist jetzt gerade noch eine Detailfrage eingekommen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr euch damit auch beschäftigt habt, weil ich habe das so aus dem Augenwecke beim Lesen, dass das, was damit auch stattfinden kann, ist, weil die Regeln dafür, was unter Abbildung von Kindesmissbrauch fällt, die sind in der Art und Weise gefasst, dass junge Menschen, die sich gegenseitig nachrichten, sexueller Natur schicken, da auch drunter fallen könnten. Muss man hier von der Kriminalisierung von Jugendlichen sprechen? Oder ist das ein anderes Thema?
Ich kann nicht sagen, wie es in anderen EU-Staaten ist. Ich kann nur für Deutschland sprechen. In Deutschland ist es tatsächlich so, dass der Austausch von kinderpornografischem Material zwischen Minderjährigen ein Straftatbestand ist. Das heißt, wenn ich 16 bin und meinem 16-jährigen Partner ein Nacktfoto von mir schicke, dann ist das eine Straftat.
Das ist im Rahmen dieser Verordnung eher eine Nebenbaustelle. Dass das auch noch zusätzliche Effekte hätte. Oder ist das ein slippery slope in eine prüdere Gesellschaft?
Nein, ich glaube, es spricht eigentlich ein Problem an, was man an anderer Stelle lösen könnten und nicht durch diese Verordnung. Denn das erste Problem ist natürlich, dass die Ermittlungsbehörden jetzt schon von der schieren Menge von Bildmaterialien überlastet sind. Und wenn dann jetzt sozusagen noch die Fotos, die sich Minderjährige zuschicken, da muss man jetzt auch nochmal wieder einhaken und sagen, okay, woher weiß ich denn, dass das zwei minderjährige Kommunikationsteilnehmerinnen sind? Das heißt, ich wäre eigentlich schon an der Stelle angekommen, wo ich sagen müsste, ich muss Age Verification, also die Sicherstellung des Alters und damit halt auch der Identität der Kommunikationspartner einführen. Aber das ist ein anderer Schauplatz. Und das würde halt heißen, dass ganz, ganz viel Bildmaterial einfach auftauchen könnte, das eigentlich total unproblematisch in Anführungsstrichen ist, aber in Deutschland halt juristisch gesehen eine Straftat. Und dieser Straftat müssen die Ermittlungsbehörden natürlich nachgehen, haben dann aber weniger Zeit, um das zu tun, was ich vorhin meinte, nämlich sich in solche Darknet-Foren zum Beispiel einzuschleusen. Und was man halt stattdessen machen könnte, wäre natürlich eine massive Aufklärungskampagne für Jugendliche, um denen zu erklären, was eigentlich das Problem mit Nacktbilder versenden ist. Ich will jetzt nicht Jugendliche davon abhalten, Nacktbilder zu versenden, bei Gott nicht, aber ich glaube, dass halt eine Aufklärungskampagne an dieser Stelle halt wesentlich angebrachter wäre.
Genau, und ich glaube, es ist vielleicht an diesem Punkt auch nochmal schlau, das nochmal aufzuschlüsseln, wie man das denn konkret umsetzen könnte. Weil, das haben wir glaube ich angerissen schon, es gibt prinzipiell zwei Möglichkeiten. Du kannst erstmal nach Bekanntem, dir bereits Bekannte Material suchen, oder du kannst sagen, ich habe hier eine zauberhafte KI und die wird pro Foto, pro Text für sich selber entscheiden, ob es hierbei eben um illegitimes Material handelt oder nicht. Beides hat massive Probleme. Wenn ich nach Bekannten Material suche, dann muss ich, wie gesagt, die Fingerabdrücke, die Hashes von allen Materialien, nach denen ich suche, muss ich runtergeladen haben auf das Gerät. Das Gerät musst du dir irgendwie kennen, um danach suchen zu können. Ich hatte das mal überschlagen, ich hoffe, ich habe da keine Multiplikationsfehler gemacht, aber das würde vermutlich auf jedem Handy zu 10 GB an Hashes führen, die da einfach rumliegen müssen. Auf dem Handy müsste ja ein Hash von jedem erdenklichen Kindesmissbrauchs, Abbildungsdings sein. Nur wenn das der Fall ist, kann das Handy das dann immer scannen. Du willst was sagen?
Oder es würde dazu führen, dass ich immer einen Teil Hash von dem Bild an den Server schicken muss und mir dann alle Hashes sozusagen angucken muss, die zu diesem Teil Hash passen und die mir runterladen würde und dann den ganzen Hash gegen die heruntergeladenen Hashes checken würde. Das würde natürlich weniger Speicherplatz kosten, aber natürlich wesentlich länger dauern, als das direkt auf dem Gerät abzugleichen.
Das ist dann auch wieder eine Frage, wie plausibel ist es, dass sie da ein super crazy fancy Kryptosystem bauen werden? Ich glaube da nicht dran. Jedenfalls, dass es die eine Version ist, dass man sagt, wir laden die ganzen Hashes runter oder wir prüfen gegen bekanntes Material. Die zweite Version ist, und danach sieht es aus nach allem, was wir gehört haben, ist, dass man das überhaupt nicht einschränkt und dass man mehr sagt, wir haben eine super coole KI auf dem Gerät, die sich jedes Foto anguckt und sich jede Chatnachricht anguckt und dann jeweils für sich entscheidet, finde ich das relativ wahrscheinlich, dass es sich dabei um eine Kindesmissbrauchserbildung oder um einen Anbahnungsversuch handelt. Und da kommen wir jetzt wieder zurück zu den Nacktfotos, die sich Jugendliche geschickt haben. Oder auch Erwachsene. Natürlich gibt es da jetzt bestimmte Ähnlichkeiten. Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, es wird immer eine Wahrscheinlichkeit geben, dass das Zeug fälschlicherweise erkannt wird, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es fälschlicherweise erkannt wird, wird natürlich größer, je mehr es sich da um sexuelle Nachrichten zwischen Erwachsenen handelt, oder ein Kind von deinem Foto am Strand, was du deiner Oma geschickt hast, oder um Nacktfotos, die sich Jugendliche gegenseitig geschickt haben. Weil das natürlich, nackte Haut, irgendwie sexuelle Begriffe, das ist dann irgendwie näher dran. Deshalb ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass das dann auch unter anderem die Sachen sind, die da landen werden. Und das realistische Szenario, von dem ich absolut ausgehe, ist, dass du davon ausgehen musst, dass wenn du ein Kind, ein Foto von deinem Strandurlaub, nacktes Kind, dass es eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt, dass das Ding entweder bei einer Kontrollstelle oder bei der Polizei landet. Und davon gibt es extrem viele Fotos. Und selbst wenn du jedes Tausendste davon weitergeleitet wird, sind das immer noch krank viele Fotos von Kindern, die wir auf einmal irgendwo sammeln.
Ich glaube, jetzt macht es so langsam bei mir, dass ich denke, das ist also eine Welt, in der wir dann leben, wo du quasi bei jeder Messenger-Nachricht, die du schreibst, die du überlegen musst, oder quasi das Gefühl hast, diese Nachricht, dieses Bild, was ich ins Thema schicke, vielleicht ist das der Punkt, wo ich Besuch von der Polizei bekomme.
Genau, und wir haben ja noch nicht über die Anbahnungsversuche gesprochen. Denn die Anbahnungsversuche erfolgen ja nicht durch Memes oder Bilder oder so etwas, sondern die erfolgen ja prinzipiell eher in Form von Textnachrichten. Das heißt, ich muss mir diesen Gedanken nicht immer nur machen, wenn ich ein Bild verschicke, sondern ich muss mir diesen Gedanken auch machen, wenn ich zum Beispiel meiner kleinen Nichte, aber egal eigentlich auch wem, eine Textnachricht schicke.
Aber da hab ich jetzt gar nicht mehr drüber nachgedacht, weil das mit dem Bild immer das vorher schnelle Thema war. Aber da frag ich mich ja, wie macht man das denn? Also Schlagwortsuche oder ist dann auch eine KI, die Textanalyse macht? Und dann sind wir ja wirklich dabei, dass der komplette Chatverlauf überwacht wird?
Genau, ganz genau so sieht es nämlich aus.
Warum hast du das nicht zuerst gesagt? Hätte ich gleich alles angezündet.
Genau, das ist nämlich das Problem, diese Anbahnungsversuche, dieses Grooming. Und Texterkennung ist relativ einfach, sage ich mal in Anführungsstrichen. Dann aber zu erkennen, wie die sprachlichen Muster sind. Und ob das jetzt ein Anbahnungsversuch ist oder nicht. Da kommt jetzt wieder dieses ganze Thema, was ich eben schon angerissen habe, Age Verification ins Spiel. Klar kann man KIs bauen, die versuchen zu erkennen anhand der Art, wie Menschen schreiben, wie das Alter von den beiden Personen, die an der Konversation beteiligt sind, schätzen kann. Aber das ist ziemlich ungenau, weil man auch weiß, dass Personen, die solche Anbahnungsversuche starten, sich eher an den Sprachgebrauch von jüngeren Nutzerinnen anpassen. Das heißt, eigentlich muss ich, um wirklich sinnvoll, Grooming-Versuche zu erkennen, nicht nur eine KI über jeden Textjagen, der rausgeht, sondern auch noch wissen, wer das am anderen Ende ist und wie alt der ist, um es wirklich sicher sagen zu können. Das heißt, es kann halt dazu kommen, dass wir uns dann wirklich ausweisen müssen, um solche Dienste nutzen zu können.
Ja, aber das ist doch super, dann haben wir doch gleich noch die Klarnamenpflicht erledigt, oder?
Genau.
Wollten wir nicht eh ein Internet haben?
Genau, also wirklich, dieser Entwurf und diese Verordnung ist eine bunte Tüte an Dingen, die wir in den letzten fünf Jahren größtenteils verhindern konnten, die jetzt nochmal anklopft und sagt so, hey, wir versuchen es nochmal, also.
Die ganzen Stehauffiguren.
Also ich bin überzeugt, ich bin überzeugt, wir meinen jetzt stellen wir drauf sozusagen keine gute Idee. Was ich bei EU-Gesetzgebungen aber immer spannend finde und das würde ich gerne heute machen, ist, weil ich das auch als jemand, der sozusagen, wenn man das als Publikum verfolgt, hab ich denke ich immer so, der Aufschrei ist immer total groß und dann denkst du so, oh mein Gott, das ist die letzte Möglichkeit das zu verhindern. Dann liest du den langen Artikel und dann steht drauf, ja und jetzt musst du noch, als nächstes ist der Kommission da irgendwie, Trilo, keine Ahnung, was auch immer, dann liest du das nach und denkst so, ah so, okay, das war so ein Schritt im Gesetzgebungsfall, aha, mhm, okay, der nächste kommt auch nochmal so. Also ich will jetzt nicht runterreden, dass es nicht dramatisch ist, weil inhaltlich ist es das natürlich, aber ich gerade bei EU-Gesetzgebung, es ist immer, finde ich, sehr schwer auf dem Schirm zu haben, an welcher Stelle stehen wir gerade und das würde ich gerne jetzt gegen Ende sozusagen, wir nähern uns glaube ich langsam, gerne noch wissen wollen. Und Punkt mit Punkt eins anfangen, ihr habt gesagt, das ist eine Verordnung, um die es geht. Was ist eine Verordnung?
Genau, also auf EU-Ebene begegnen uns meistens zwei Arten. Das sind einmal die Verordnung und einmal die Richtlinien. Die Richtlinien sind solche Gesetzgebungen, die dann auch noch von Staaten auf nationaler Ebene umgesetzt und durchgesetzt werden müssen, während Verordnungen sozusagen direkt von oben erlassen werden und dann auch direkt umgesetzt, also nicht nochmal in nationale Gesetzgebung umgesetzt werden müssen, sondern so wie das in dem Entwurf steht, gilt es dann auch. Da gibt es dann auch keine zwei Meinungen drüber. So, das ist eine Verordnung. Und ich kann das total gut verstehen, dass das für viele auf EU-Ebene immer sehr intransparent und schwierig zu verstehen ist. Man muss auch dazu sagen, diese EU-Ebenen malen langsam. Wir sprechen da häufig nicht von Monaten, die das dauern kann, bis das entschieden ist, sondern von Jahren. Man muss da immer einen sehr langen Atem haben. Und das liegt daran, dass das ein bisschen aufwendiger ist oder komplizierter als bei uns, vielleicht im Bundestag der Fall. Wir haben sozusagen drei unterschiedliche Gremien. Also wir haben einmal die Kommission. Wir haben am Anfang gesagt, dieser Gesetzentwurf kommt von der Kommission. Die Kommission macht einen Vorschlag für einen Gesetzesentwurf. Und dann gibt es noch den...
Warte mal, wenn wir jetzt schon eine kleine Einführung in die EU-Gesetzgebung machen, was ist die Kommission?
Das ist ein bisschen wie die Regierung. Also das sind die Leute, die sind auch mehr oder weniger gewählt und die bringen die Gesetzesvorschläge in diese ganze Mühle. Riesige Gebäude in Brüssel. Und jetzt, wenn wir in diesem Gesetzgebungsprozess sind, die machen einen Vorschlag. Und die haben auch, wie so die Spitze, das ist die Ursula von der Leyen aktuell, und dann haben die die einzelnen Referate, könnte man sagen. Also gibt es das Kommissariat und da gibt es dann zum Beispiel eine Innenkommissarin. Das ist eben die jene Ilva Johansson, von der wir gerade geredet haben. Und die, unter ihrer Leitung, die hat sicherlich ein sehr großes Team, ist da ein entsprechender Gesetzentwurf entstanden.
Also, ich will nochmal zusammenfassen. Es gibt also die EU-Kommission, quasi so eine Art Regierung oder das Analogons einer Landesregierung.
Das ist die Exekutive sozusagen.
Das ist die Exekutive. Die haben jetzt eine Verordnung vorgeschlagen. Verordnung heißt, in dem Moment, wenn die entschieden wird, gilt die auch so in allen EU-Ländern. Punkt.
Genau.
So, aber sie ist in Anführungszeichen nur ein Vorschlag. Der Vorschlag wird jetzt gerade heiß diskutiert. Was passiert im Gesetz, was ist der nächste Schritt, was sind die Aussichten im Gesetzgebungsprozess?
Als nächstes geht es an die anderen beiden Organe, nämlich einmal den EU-Ministerinnenrat und einmal an das Parlament.
So, jetzt sozusagen, als jemand, der nicht so viel Ahnung hat von der EU, Parlament, okay, da wird gewählt, da geben wir selber das Stimmrad, das ist ein Parlament, aber Ministerinnenrat, ihr habt doch gerade gesagt, die EU-Kommission ist so eine Art Regierung mit Ministern. Was ist der Ministerrat?
Genau, also die Kommission ist mit Kommissaren und der Ministerinnenrat, da gibt es dann auch unterschiedliche Fachministerinnenräte, also zum Beispiel, was hier interessant ist, den für Inneres. Da wäre dann zum Beispiel für Deutschland Nancy Faeser drin.
Also das heißt, der Ministerinnenrat ist nicht sozusagen ein Rat aus EU-Ministern, sondern da sitzen die Fachminister aus den jeweiligen Ländern in einem Rat zusammen.
Genau.
Das ist so die Vertretung, ja.
Parlament und Ministerinnenrat sprechen jetzt darüber.
Genau, die sprechen intern miteinander darüber, also der Ministerinnenrat diskutiert das für sich und das EU-Parlament diskutiert das für sich. So.
Macht das EU-Parlament dann auch eine Abstimmung? Also wird darüber gewählt im Parlament?
Irgendwann wird darüber gewählt im Parlament, genau. Und dann gilt's? Nein, noch nicht. Also das ist das Wichtige. Also es gibt sowohl im Ministerinnenrat als auch im Parlament eine Abstimmung darüber. Und wenn das irgendwo scheitert, dann ist es erst mal sozusagen vorbei. Und wenn es irgendwo stecken bleibt, weil die Mühlen der Verwaltung malen langsam, dann dauert das halt so lange, wie es halt eben dauert, bis das Thema durchdiskutiert ist.
Das heißt, es reicht, wenn es in einer von diesen drei Institutionen schief geht. Also wenn alle drei Institutionen sagt, finden wir geil, dann ist es beschlossene Sache.
Genau, und eine ist ja jetzt schon raus. Weil die Kommission hat ja schon gesagt, das finden wir super.
Aber wie ist denn das, wenn jetzt sozusagen das Parlament sagt, also im Prinzip ja, aber folgende Änderungen? Geht dann die ganze Runde von vorher los?
Nee, also die können dann sozusagen ein bisschen Ping-Pong damit spielen. Also jeder kann seine Änderungsanträge einbringen. Und ganz, ganz zum Schluss, das kennen wir alle, also für mich ist immer so in meinem Kopf ganz fest verankert, wenn wir im Trilog sind, dann haben wir eigentlich fast verloren. So, also die versuchen sich dann sozusagen auf eine Form zu einigen, mit der sie alle leben können. Und wenn sie das nicht kommen, dann kommt ganz zum Schluss halt dieser Trilog, wo sie es dann noch mal final versuchen zusammenzubringen.
Kann man sich das vorstellen? Wieder setzen sie sich gleichzeitig an den Tisch und reden miteinander? So, jetzt habt ihr ja schon am Anfang gesagt, irgendwie anzünden ist eine Option. An welcher Stelle kann das denn am besten scheitern, wenn ich die Frage mal so schnell darf?
Das ist tatsächlich eine Frage, die wir nicht so einfach beantworten. Also es kann an sehr vielen Stellen scheitern. Und wir konnten uns auch, also es gibt glaube ich keine bessere oder schlechtere Stelle. Grundsätzlich können wir erstmal versuchen, auf die jeweilige Ministerin, in diesem Fall Nancy Faeser, Druck auszuüben und zu sagen, hey, das ist eine ziemlich doofe Idee. Bitte tu was dagegen. Und sie vor allen Dingen an den Koalitionsvertrag zu erinnern, in dem ein Recht auf Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung verankert ist. Das ist sozusagen der erste Angriffspunkt. Und der zweite Angriffspunkt ist, seine Parlamentarierinnen zu kontaktieren. Und zu sagen, okay, das ist eine ganz blöde Idee, die anzurufen oder den zu schreiben und den zu erklären, warum das ein Problem ist mit dieser Chatkontrolle.
Jetzt ist es doch aber so, wenn ich die Medien richtig verfolgt habe, ist so toll, wie ich von den Medien spreche. Ich bin ja selber dazu. Anyways, wenn ich die Medien verfolgt habe, sieht das doch gar nicht so schlecht aus, weil vor allen Dingen die Deutschen auch eine Frau Feser schon gesagt haben, so eine gute Idee ist die Chatkontrolle. Lass mal nicht machen. Ist der Drops nicht schon gelutscht?
Nein, ganz so einfach ist es leider nicht. Wenn eine Ministerin twittert und sagt, sie findet das total unterstützend wert, das muss man ja erstmal historisch oder chronologisch betrachten. Das ist so ein bisschen wie bei dieser ganzen Hackback-Geschichte. Dann ist ein bisschen Zeit vergangen. Wir haben schon Wetten abgeschlossen, wie lange es wohl dauern wird, bis sie wieder zurückrudern wird. Und dann hat sie gedacht, nein doch nicht. Vielleicht ist das doch nicht die gute Idee. Aber grundsätzlich ist das noch nicht 100% offiziell. Ich würde sagen, es wackelt. Denn Nancy Faeser sieht halt auch oder sagt halt auch, es gibt dieses Problem und es ist ein Riesenproblem. Und wir müssen da was gegen tun.
Genau, da könnte man jetzt sagen, sie hat jetzt die einmalige Chance, das tatsächlich zu zeigen, dass sie da technisch verstanden hat, was in dem Gesetzentwurf drin steht und sieht, dass das, was passieren muss, nicht ein Scanning von Ende zu Ende verschlüsselter Kommunikation ist, sondern ganz andere Sachen sind. Und hat die Chance zu zeigen, dass sie da nicht irgendwelche Symbolpolitik hinterherläuft. Weil, wie gesagt, das ist sicherlich gut gemeint, aber das, was da gefordert wird mit dem Scanning von verschlüsselter Kommunikation, das wird nichts bringen und das ist total gefährlich. Und deshalb wünschen wir ihr natürlich, dass sie die Weitsicht und politische Stärke haben wird, da entsprechend den Koalitionsvertrag umzusetzen und unseren deutschen und europäischen Werten gerecht zu werden und zu sagen, ne, das machen wir so nicht.
Also nur, um das mal klar zu sagen, ihr arbeitet nicht daran, da irgendwie eine Umsetzung zu finden, die da machbar ist, sondern das Ding soll einfach weg.
Genau, also da kann man vielleicht mal drauf zurückkommen. Also es ist ein bisschen rechtlich und ein bisschen trocken. Also, diese Gesetzesentwurf ist unter Artikel 140 der EU angeordnet und das ist der Bereich, der sich auf Märkte bezieht. So. Und was das heißt, das ist ein Gesetz, das nur eine Umsetzung von Maßnahmen beschreibt, die in Märkten, also von Unternehmen umgesetzt werden können. Das heißt, jegliche Kompromissvorschläge, die wir uns überlegen würden, wie mehr Prävention, mehr Gelder für Ermittlungsbehörden und so weiter und so fort, die könnten wir da gar nicht einbringen, weil das keine Sachen sind, die im Markt geregelt werden können.
Okay, ich meinte jetzt natürlich gar nicht so sehr die Frage, was machen wir gegen Abbildung von Kindesmissbrauch, sondern ich rede jetzt von diesem technischen Ding. Also von diesem, davon, dass irgendwie Anbieter von Kommunikationsinfrastrukturen sicherstellen sollen, dass was passiert, das soll als Konzept doch einfach weg.
Ja, definitiv.
Wie macht man das?
Das soll einfach weg.
Das ist gefährlich und muss weg anzünden.
Und die anschließende politische Diskussion ist sozusagen, dass man dann sagt, so liebe Leute, das Thema ist wichtig, aber das muss man an anderer Stelle abfinden, nämlich nicht bei Artikel 140, wo es um den Markt geht, sondern...
Genau, und das ist halt wichtig zu verstehen. Alle Leute, die sagen, ja, aber ihr müsst doch Kompromisse anbieten usw. Wir bieten diese Kompromisse gerne an. Es muss aber allen Menschen klar sein, dass wir sie nicht mit diesem Gesetz in dieser Art, unter dieser Aufhängung lösen können, sondern dass wir sagen müssen, geht mal zurück zu euren Whiteboards und denkt euch was Neues aus und denkt nochmal drüber nach, wo man das wirklich sinnvoll aufhängen kann.
Und vor allem macht das besser, weil also niemand wird bezweifeln, dass das ein riesiges Problem ist. Das haben wir vielleicht auch noch nicht in ausführlichem Volumen genug erzählt. Also Kindesmissbrauch ist eine schreckliche Sache. Das Versenden von Kindesmissbrauch, Missbrauch, Abbildungen muss auf jeden Fall verhindert werden. Diese Leute muss man finden. Diese Leute müssen strafrechtlich belangt werden. Das heißt, was wir wollen, ist eigentlich nur, sind wirksame Maßnahmen, die tatsächlich was bringen und nicht dieser technisch wackelige Quatsch.
Gut, dem ist eigentlich nichts hinzuzufügen.
Aber vielleicht noch...
Das einzige, was mich jetzt frage ist, baut ihr auf so Einflakzonen, also die Leute sollen jetzt ihre Parlamentarier anrufen, oder Frau Feser daran erinnern, dass sie doch bitte einen Koalitionsvertrag einhalten, oder gibt es so Arbeit an sowas wie irgendwie Uploadfilter gegen Demos, Dinge tun? Gibt es Stichtage, Deadlines, Formbriefe?
Also erstmal grundsätzlich kann man sagen, es wäre natürlich cool, wenn ihr das jetzt schon machen würdet, also Abgeordnete kontaktieren und Nancy Feser kontaktieren. Aber was halt besonders wichtig ist, ist, dass die mediale Aufmerksamkeit bestehen bleibt. Und das bekommen wir auf jeden Fall hin, wenn wir dezentral, regelmäßig Proteste dagegen organisieren. Und es wird auch noch einen offenen Brief von der E3 geben zu diesem ganzen Thema.
Netzakt, gewissliche Organisation, die auf der EU-Ebene arbeitet.
Genau, es ist die European Digital Rights Association. Da sind diverse NGOs, unter anderem auch der CCC, Mitglied, die ganz, ganz tolle Arbeit im Bereich digitale Menschenrechte machen. Und es gibt auch eine Unterschriftensammlung von Campact mit einem Appell an Nancy Faeser. Da kann man auch immer noch unterschreiben. Genau, also da kann man ganz, ganz viel machen, was wir halt wirklich versuchen müssen. Wir haben eigentlich ein Super-Medien-Narrativ in Deutschland gerade, und das müssen wir wirklich versuchen, aufrechtzuerhalten und auch sozusagen Nancy Faeser darin bestärken und sagen so, das ist deine Chance, vertrauenswürdige Kommunikation und Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung zu retten. Bitte mach das für uns.
Du kannst eine von den Guten sein, wir glauben an dich. Genau, ja, das ist das, das braucht es. Und da kann ich euch vielleicht nochmal ermutigen. Also die ganzen Deadlines wissen wir zwar alle noch nicht, aber wir sind auf jedes bisschen Fotoaktionen. Und das kann auch ganz klein sein. Also wir haben tatsächlich da zwei E-Mail-Adressen. Eine davon ist demo-at-chat-kontrolle.eu. Das schicken wir auch alles nochmal in die Show Notes rein. Schreibt, also wenn ihr ja Bock habt, auch wenn ihr einfach nur ein paar Friends habt, schreibt uns da gerne. Ich glaube, es wäre extrem cool, da jetzt einfach, wenn es anfängt, dass Dinge passieren. Und wenn ihr Lust habt, ein paar Friends aus eurer Stadt, egal wo ihr wohnt, zu sammeln und da so ein bisschen Betreuung aus Berlin braucht, euch wünscht, schreibt mir gerne. Ich denke mir da gerne mit euch was aus. Oder baut euch selber auch gerne Transbiz und Schilder und so. Und fangt mit kleinen, coolen Fotoaktionen an. Und, ähm, genau, oder Rave-Demos oder was auch immer. Ähm, alles ist drin. Alles finden wir super.
Rave-Demos mit Betreuung aus Berlin, das klingt gar nicht so.
Liefern wir alles.
Das war jetzt ein wilder Ritt. Und wir haben auch über tausend Dinge nicht gesprochen. Aber das reicht erst mal, oder? Weil es ist ja 5-stellig genug, so wie es ist.
Genau, ich glaube, wir müssen alle tief Luft holen. Wir müssen uns allen im Klaren sein, dass das ein Marathon wird und kein Sprint. Und dass wir wirklich alle zusammen dagegen aufstehen müssen. Und auch nicht aufhören dürfen, dagegen aufzustehen. Und das ist jetzt der Anfang mit coolen, dezentralen Fotoaktionen. Ich glaube, das macht super viel Spaß. Und es werden bestimmt auch noch Dinge auf uns zukommen, die weniger Spaß machen, als witzige Fotoaktionen dagegen zu tun. Und ich glaube, wenn man da sich eine gute Crew zusammensucht, mit der man das zusammen macht, dann kann das wirklich eine gute Sache sein. Und dann kann man das auch sehr lange durchhalten. Und diesen langen Atem sollten wir uns auch beibehalten. Denn unsere zu Ende verschüsselte Kommunikation muss geschützt werden. Und das haben wir gerade noch gar nicht so gesagt. Wir müssen eine anlasslose Massenüberwachung von allen Menschen in Europa verhindern.
Nichts Gerirres als das. Bottom line, das Ding ist gefährlich, das Ding muss weg. Macht Demos. Kommt zu Demos. Jetzt.
Also klar, in diesem Sinne möchte ich bei euch bedanken, dass ihr das so schön und einleuchtend nochmal erklärt habt, euch geduldig allen Fragen gestellt habt. Und ich möchte jetzt noch eine überraschende Wendung nehmen, bevor ich mich verabschiede. Und das ist Viktor. Da kommt jetzt gleich ein Song. Du kannst uns, hab ich gehört, genaueres dazu erzählen. Was ist eigentlich die Geschichte hinter diesem Song? Wo kommt das her?
Welches Song ist das überhaupt? Was ist hier los? Eine diffus mir bekannte Datenschutz-Elektropunk-Band, die irgendwann mal dazu aufgebrochen ist, Musik zu machen. Und wie es sich so begab, ist das tatsächlich... Wir reden eigentlich nur zu zweit über unsere Band. Ich halte das deshalb jetzt mal ganz kurz. Ich bin da durchaus involviert, weil ich die eine Hälfte von Systemabsturz bin, was genau das Musikprojekt ist, von dem dieser Song ist. Dementsprechend kenne ich den Song sehr gut, weil ich ihn bestimmt tausendmal gehört habe, während ich den Beat gebaut habe und ihn gemischt habe und mir das ganze Gedüdel im Hintergrund ausgedacht habe. Deshalb ist es natürlich irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob das auch jetzt der Autosong ist, aber das kann ich dazu erzählen oder hast du Fragen?
Ja, aber die will ich jetzt wiederum nicht stellen, weil du gesagt hast, ihr redet nur zu zweit darüber.
Man kann uns doch zu zweit einladen, buchen. Wir sind buchbar, sowohl für Festivals als auch für Podcasts, für Chaosradio Folgen.
Alles klar, liebes Chaosradio Redaktions-Team, bei dem ich mich an dieser Stelle auch noch recht herzlich für die Sendungsvorbereitung bedanken möchte. Ich glaube, dieses Mal war es vor allen Dingen Mo, der es gemacht hat. Und Danni Mo, ohne den wir heute gar nicht hier technisch zustande gekommen wären. Vielen Dank euch, vielen Dank auch an den Rest. Und mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Heute wichtiger denn die, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.